[Music]
That was when Neil was in elementary school We
practiced fighting in pairs
[Music]
I was a popular person, what happened?
Don't worry, leave it to me Don't
worry
[music]
Guys,
next time
we'll team up with Neil Don't let the high schoolers get in the way
No one can beat you Haha Nick I'm better than you
Teacher
Neil
I feel like I'm going to die We've played together a lot since then
Ah, for example, wrestling,
darts, and baseball
We've become even better friends
Collecting pictures of me, that's all
I named my doll "meat"
I've got plenty of drinks ready Drinks are full of
nostalgic memories Hey
hey, talk about yesterday instead of those days